the book is i don't know what you uh
know me from and you talk in here about
how you have this experience where
people they know you yeah they're not
sure what they know you from yes that's
why i called the book that title um yeah
people
they come up to me a lot and they demand
for me to tell them
what they know me from
um it becomes my problem to
figure out what project i've been in
that they that they recognize me from so
i've i call it fan profiling because i
think you can tell i can i feel like i
can kind of tell when i look at somebody
what their favorite thing i've been in
it sort of just what they recognize me
from like i was recently flying from
toronto to new york and my customs
officer bill was his name
he was an older gentleman with a
mustache and i was guessing two and a
half men for that one
i was wrong by the way it turns out bill
doesn't watch television or movies
so i don't know what bill knew me from
but he wouldn't
but he knew you and he was not handing
over my passport until he figured it out
together
so he's so you have people saying to you
what do i know and they don't let you go
until you yeah hit the thing which is
frustrating yeah it's kind of
frustrating especially when it's like
yeah he's got like a really important
document of mine in my hands
and i wanted it back have you ever had
people where it's like okay i think this
person
or this person gets it right yes and you
think they've gotten it right yes i was
waiting uh in line for the valet
recently and a woman was like aren't you
an actress she was a little mad about it
actually i was like yeah but it's a good
thing and um she said you're in 27
dresses and i was like i am in 27
dresses she was like i thought so and
then she got kind of nice and then she
was like what else
but we just did the thing it's over you
guessed it yeah you were right yeah no
no you need more so i said the wedding
planner because i was like that's
another wedding rom-com like i feel like
this is in her wheelhouse and she's like
no
and i was like i didn't i didn't know
where to go from there i i i went 13
going on 30. she wasn't happy she wasn't
happy my car came thankfully and i got
to escape the situation she chased you
like she was pregnant so she couldn't
chase which is probably another reason
she was crabby she was really pregnant
but
i hear it's uncomfortable you hear it's
uncomfortable yes
my favorite is when people uh
people will say like hey conan and then
they'll they'll pull someone out of the
back like i'm at a deli counter they'll
pull someone out of the back who's
maybe from another country even probably
they pulled them out of the back and
they were like you know what that is you
know that hasn't been like no
no no you know that you don't know what
that is
you don't know that is and then they say
to me god tell him tell him
i'm like
i what am i i suddenly have to tell you
who i am yeah i'm a delightful
ginger-head leprechaun
as a child remember yes i do remember
just barely candy was there in a shorts
and a little sailor suit
i did i did
yeah
it was a good old day
customs changed back then
oh i'll get you
i'll get you judy graham yes i know you